IBM's acquisition of a robotic process automation provider,
the release of IBM Cloud Databases for EnterpriseDB,
and the 2020 Top Rated Awards from TrustRadius
- all on this episode of  IBM Cloud Now.
Hey everyone, I'm Ian,
and I'm excited to bring you the latest and greatest news and announcements
from IBM Cloud.
Recently, IBM announced a definitive agreement
to acquire a Brazilian software provider of robotic process automation,
informally referred to as WDG Automation.
The blog linked below has the full company name in Portuguese.
With this acquisition, we plan to bring WDG Automation’s RPA
and AI-driven chatbot capabilities
to 2 areas where enterprises have critical automation needs:
transforming business processes
and managing IT operations.
The acquisition will strengthen our AI-infused automation platform
- making it one of the most fully-equipped platforms
for CIOs and COOs looking to
quickly transform and standardize
business and IT operations
for growth, efficiency and resiliency.
Ultimately, the plan is to include RPA capabilities
across the IBM Cloud Pak® family,
starting with the Cloud Pak® for Automation for business processes
and the Cloud Pak® for Multicloud  Management for IT operations.
For more information about this exciting announcement,
please read the blog linked in the description below.
We'll also be holding an "Ask Me Anything" webinar
with Mike Gilfix, VP of Offering Management for Cloud Integration,
on July 15th, so make sure you register.
Next up, we've got the the release of IBM Cloud Databases for EnterpriseDB.
EDB PostgreSQL Advanced Server
joins a broad suite of powerful database technologies
on the IBM Cloud Databases platform.
It's a fully managed, production-ready, Database-as-a-Service
built from the ground up for scale and security of enterprise workloads.
Modernizing your data with Databases for EnterpriseDB
enables you to save costs, gain efficiencies,
and power innovation for new applications.
This new release provides compatibility with Oracle,
offers a boost to productivity, and increases security.
Hit the link in the description for a full rundown of all the features
and info on how to get rolling with Databases for EnterpriseDB.
And finally, I wanted to close out this episode with a little bit of celebratory news
from the Trust Radius 2020 Top Rated Awards,
where IBM Cloud has been recognized as a leader in several categories.
The Trust Radius Top Rated Awards are the industry standard
for unbiased recognition of B2B technology products,
and are based entirely upon customer feedback.
Since our customers are our top priority
and these awards are based on their unfiltered feedback,
we are thrilled that IBM Cloud Bare Metal Servers,
IBM Cloud Object Storage,
and IBM Cloud Virtual Servers won in the IaaS category.
Additionally, the IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service
won in the Container Management category,
and IBM Cloud Databases won in both the Database-as-a-Service
and Relational Databases categories.
A sincere thanks to each and every one of our customers who submitted reviews,
because your feedback shapes what we do.
If you'd like to learn more about TrustRadius or the awards,
including the criteria and IBM's scores,
see the link below.
Thanks for joining me today for this episode of IBM Cloud Now.
If you're interested in learning more about the topics I've covered,
make sure you explore the links in the description of this video.
And, of course, please don't forget to subscribe to our channel
to stay up-to-date on what's going on in the cloud, now.